you see harry i've searched and searched
for something
some small detail when we first
discovered harry potter we were totally
surprised by all the unbelievable twists
and turns from start to finish
but it turns out that they were actually
dropping tons of hints about what was to
come
long before anything really happened
like how about the fact that snape was
working with dumbledore all along
we had no idea but looking back there
were so many clues
today we're checking out all of the
foreshadowing that we totally missed in
harry potter
no one can
know per snape we were never totally
sure where his loyalties lay
but it turns out that we missed a
million clues that he was one of the
good guys all along
if you watch closely he tries to protect
harry in almost every movie
in tiny subtle deliberately hidden ways
like teaching him his most useful spell
experience
to confronting professor quirrell on
harry's behalf
to taking out the carrots during his
jewel with professor mcgonagall
and so many more how am i to pay for all
this
i haven't any money in book one one of
the first things that hagrid does with
the 11 year old harry
is to take him to gringott's bank in the
book hagrid tells harry that gringotts
is so secure that anyone would be
mad to try and rob it while this little
line didn't make it into the movie
it is a big moment of foreshadowing
because six books later in the deathly
hallows
harry ron and hermione actually wind up
breaking into gringotts to free a dragon
trapped within
but there were two weren't there where's
the other one
horcruxes are one of the most important
parts of the entire harry potter saga
and long before we knew what they were
we saw one
that's right in the order of the phoenix
while clearing out sirius's house to
make space for the order
harry stumbles across a locket that no
one can open
well in the deathly hallows it turns out
that that locket
had been a horcrux all along
professor dumbledore sir in the very
beginning of the first book we read
about a dark night on privet drive
where dumbledore professor mcgonagall
and hagrid leave the newly orphaned
harry potter at the dursley home
hagrid arrives on the famous enchanted
motorcycle and dumbledore asks where he
got it
hagrid casually mentions that a young
sirius black lent it to him
even though we had no idea at the time
this was the first mention of a
character who had become more important
than we could ever have imagined
i'd like you to see it in the half-blood
prince dumbledore begins to take harry
into his memories in order to teach him
about voldemort
one of these memories is the time when
dumbledore first met the very young
tom riddle in a very quick flash we see
seven stones lined up on tom riddle's
windowsill
foreshadowing the fact that he will
eventually split his soul into seven
pieces
making him almost immortal
seven is a very important number in the
harry potter series
it pops up over and over again one of
the creepiest ways that we never noticed
was when harry became the quidditch
captain
his jersey number is seven this
foreshadows the fact that harry himself
is the seventh horcrux and we all know
what that meant
i wonder when harry first gets his one
from ollivander he learns that he and
voldemort both received wands with a
phoenix feather core
the only two ever made olivander tells
harry that the one
chooses the wizard mr potter and hints
that there might be a connection between
harry and voldemort
but it wouldn't be until the end of the
goblet of fire that we learn about the
twin wands
and even later in the deathly hallows
about just how important it is that the
one chooses a wizard
after all that stuff you did in your
books books can be misleading you wrote
them
oh professor lockhart so handsome so
full of lies
in the chamber of secrets gilderoy
lockhart becomes a defense against a
dark arts teacher at hogwarts
and everyone quickly realizes just how
fake his amazing stories actually are
well one clue hidden in plain sight in
his office might have tipped us off
earlier
if we had noticed it a wig sitting right
there on lockhart's desk
well it's no big deal if he wants to
wear one it does indicate that he isn't
telling the whole truth about who he
really is
i am professor tradome most people at
hogwarts don't take professor trelawny's
predictions of the future all that
seriously but maybe they should
especially considering that she actually
predicted dumbledore's fate
way back in the prisoner of azkaban in
one scene in the great hall dumbledore
stands up to invite trolloni to sit with
him
and the 11 other people at the table she
declines saying that the first person to
stand up from the table of 13 will be
the first to die
foreshadowing the fact that dumbledore
would meet that fate years later
the rule requirement only appears when a
person has real need of it
one of the most important rooms in
hogwarts has got to be the room of
requirement
in which harry ron and hermione would
put together dumbledore's army
during the terrible reign of dolores
umbridge little did we know that
dumbledore
himself had actually mentioned the room
in passing way back in the goblet of
fire
when he casually mentions stumbling upon
a bathroom that he was never able to
find again
look i don't know what happened tonight
and i don't know why
you just did while no one guessed that
harry would wind up a hogwarts champion
in the tri-wizard tournament
it turned out that he and ron actually
guessed all the tasks by chance
a year before they took place in the
prisoner of azkaban
they tire of their divination homework
and start randomly throwing out ideas
for what could happen to them in the
future
including harry suffering burns being
betrayed by a friend
and almost losing a big fight fast
forward to the goblet of fire
and all of those things would happen to
him for real
the boy who lived come to die
we first encounter the mysterious and
awe-inspiring centaurs in the
philosopher's stone
when harry is saved from voldemort and
quirrell's attack
in the forbidden forest by ferenz after
harry leaves with hagrid
another centaur named bane tells ferenz
that he shouldn't have interfered with
the planet's intentions
which basically means he knew that harry
was supposed to meet his
end in the forest he just got the date
wrong by about
six years ten points
to neville longbottom many
many years after the gang's first year
at hogwarts we would learn about
dumbledore's troubled past
and relationship with his friend
grindelwald and yet
at the end of the philosopher's stone he
gives us a hint about it
even if we had no idea at the time when
handing out points to determine who has
won the house cup
he gives 10 points to neville longbottom
because while it takes a great deal of
courage to stand up to our enemies
but a great deal more to stand up to
your friends
something that dumbledore would know a
lot about
mysterious thing time we don't often see
members of the wizarding world
interacting with parts of the muggle
world but one instance of very clever
foreshadowing does just
that in the prisoner of azkaban when we
see harry at the leaky cauldron for the
first time
we get a very quick glimpse of a man
reading a copy of stephen hawking's book
a brief history of time this little wink
lets us know just how important time and
time travel are going to be
in the rest of this particular story
something i might have overlooked even
though the deathly hallows become
something that is so important to harry
potter that
we can't imagine not being aware of them
it wasn't until the very end that we
actually learn what they are
and yet all the way back in the goblet
of fire we saw the famous symbol for the
first time without even knowing it
right before the final event of the
tournament when dumbledore is speaking
to harry about barty kreutz jr
he looks into a glass case in his office
and comes face to face with a statue of
the hallows
how's that for foreshadowing every time
i get close to an answer
it slips away there is so much hidden in
these incredible books and movies
we could watch them a hundred times and
never catch it all
did we miss your favorite moment of
foreshadowing let us know in the
comments
and don't forget to subscribe to keep up
with the latest videos from the things